elles sont seize équipes engagées dans
ce tournoi de football avec le même
objectif décrocher ce trophée de
l'association jeunesse de la ligne des
bambous
une rencontre sportive pour ces jeunes
venus des quatre coins de l'île
avec également une équipe mauricienne je
parle pour moi c'est que le championnat
du jeune état cern pour qui peu ses
paroles dans ce qu'elle fait que les
études souvent se rend compte entre
elles dans le sud et le fait d'avoir
aujourd'hui des équipes venant du porc
venant de saint denis venant de sainte
anne de sa fille ça permet de créer sous
les unités haut niveau de notre île et
surtout de faire jouer les enfants ça
c'est important
le plus important c'est qu'ils jouent
pour la troisième édition l'association
jeunesse ligne des bambous organise son
tournoi pour ces jeunes footballeurs de
moins de 13 ans l'occasion pour les
organisateurs de dénicher de nouveaux
talents et promouvoir les valeurs du
sport auprès de ces adolescents ça fait
longtemps que les jeunes puissent se
confronter avec oman c'est à dire qu'on
est dans le sport c'est la fraternité
on leur montre que des gestes simples en
sport qu'il faut part je dirais fumure
le zamal et cetera
c'est simple éducation afin que demain
matin y deviennent des adieux et qui
plus est qui sont là des adieux
responsable pour retrouver les équipes
de la région et pour voir quelles sont
les meilleures équipes de l'art n'y a
que sept jours d'être le meilleur leur
est dû bah oui mais bon faut rester sur
sa ligne est bon mais il faut fêter pas
baissé de niveau
c'était toujours santé n'est pas de
l'expérience
mais peu après plus tard devenir pro bah
j'aime jouer c'est mon foot c'est le
foot c'est ça donne envie d'y jouer
pourquoi parce que sa maison ce plaisir
jusqu'à la maison n'a rien à faire quoi
ces mules faire du foot l'équipe de la
jeanne d'arc gagne cette troisième
édition aux tirs au but face au saint
denis fc
une journée soutenue par le département
de la réunion au plus proche du monde
sportif réunionnais